la fiebre del Oro vuelve a Uruguay esta
vez de la mano del turismo en la
provincia de ribera se pone de moda a
buscar este metal precioso como
diversión tal y como lo hicieron
centenares de personas en el siglo XIX y
XX podemos ir y jugar un poco Buscando
oro nosotros mismos con un garrimpeiro
con un Buscador de oro artesanal y
también podemos meternos
abajo de la tierra en las Galerías
subterráneas antiguas y de verdad darnos
cuenta lo que era trabajar ahí adentro y
lo duro que tiene que haber sido la vida
para los mineros en aquel momento los
habitantes de esta región fronteriza con
Brasil quieren demostrar que son más que
una zona Ganadera y que la provincia
encierra la historia de la
industrialización del Uruguay se empieza
a poblar de Aventureros de gente que no
tiene nada para perder en el lugar que
está y decide probar suerte y hacerse
rico que después
no todos lo logran no pero la esperanza
lo tienen todos hoy en día los
Aventureros son los turistas que cada
vez son más
encajado entre los gigantes turísticos
latinoamericanos de Argentina y Brasil
Uruguay suele pasar desapercibido pero
como en la ruta del Oro Busca
reinventarse según cifras
gubernamentales solo en el primer
trimestre de 2023 llegaron al país a más
de un millón de visitantes un 11% más
que en 2019 antes de la pandemia